assalamo alaikom what a mental a better
case involving success focus I was doing
well before the videos class I just
wanted to address the few issues point
number one it might see Malcolm speak
and read to him or mocking him now what
we need to understand in the dialogue we
should be respectful to the individual
the opposite person whose games is
genuine right now this person is a
individual who instructs the Prophet in
for Islam and is lying he lies
unfortunately and he causes interest it
has caused trouble so that's why I want
you guys to understand that the way I'm
talking to him and is because he
deserves it now this doesn't mean you
need to understand it if somebody in
social swear that you don't drop to
their levels because I don't I didn't
disrespect them right I don't know where
I might insult him maybe I was walking
away my team rule but I think that's the
least that I can do to towards him when
speaking besides the point
anyway now his claim my claim is this
right he kids we come from energy energy
to eternal my issue is this if energy we
have conscious I'm a conscious being
I have rationality and I have will right
he's saying that we come from energy I'm
saying is that the case how can energy
give me conscious rationality and the
will when energy itself is enough
conscious rationality and a will imagine
these guys imagine this guy's if I said
I have a would a bottle empty bottle and
if I said if we give that bottle enough
time we will have a chocolate fudge cake
with strawberries inside yes now the
question here is to ask this if the
bottle doesn't have the element of
making a chocolate fudge cake with extra
brownies and extra strawberries
how would it ever give us that it
doesn't have it in the first place
so I have a human being how can i
evolved from that energy that particle
whatever it may be right if it doesn't
have the qualities of consciousness
rationality and of the will so this is
my argument now for him to account that
he goes to something called the double
slit experiment I'm going to show you
guys on the screen when it's more atomic
atomic particles being fired between two
slits right when it's not being observed
it acts like a wave right they have a
second wave as you can see on the screen
right however when they put a camera
there and it's being observed
acts like a particle you only see
Tuesdays instead of four or five now in
this claim is which is a bit crazy and
no scientist is coming and saying this
and even it once it one of them equals
it's a theory he's just claiming that no
evidence now they're saying that all
energy has consciousness that evidence
that is consciousness it's making
conscious decision
my point is very clear and very simple
yep because the guy came he came very
confident while fortunately we didn't
understand this point now every time
it's been observed every time it acts
like a particle every single time it's
being observed it acts nothing but like
a particle it doesn't act like a wave
my question is this if something is
acting the same way every time there's
something dead
that means the systemic that means it's
just following one law right now the
question is this let me give you guys an
example let's use Siri right hey Siri
look it just reacted right okay let's
track this right back again yeah hey
Siri here we have to begin hey Siri now
it is systemic every time I say
something it acts a certain way does
that mean I'm going to come to the
conclusion that theory is conscious and
series making conscious decisions Siri
hello Siri how's your dating today did
you have dairy on e is equal to respond
to me and say oh brother Ali hamdulillah
I had at least what they just played a
falafel ball and I'm going to have some
food
the assist availability okay is
conscious but it's not so the fact that
every time I say something it acts the
same way just as the way if I go press
the home button the screen effect home
button you get me trying to say so my
question is very simple if you are
claiming that energy is conscious why is
every time it's being observed a
abstract a particle instead of a waste
let's watch the video and find out in
shala it's funny
he ends up trying to speak to my
trainers let's see if my trainers
respond
under different arrangements and robust
calm down is this anything it's made it
made us about my shoes made of subatomic
particle energy go ahead everything is
anything I anything yet it why is it
that I have wishes
you're a really got brain and a never
done oh he's my brother comfort bring
along if you want okay
I have consciously my irrational I ever
will I will do I like or they have
created why doesn't my tweezers right oh
okay remember break it down on you break
it down now boys you've heard me say D
for any time before Holly after one year
or have it has not investigated let's
break it down to you don't write Mexican
break yourself now is everybody where is
everybody aware of the double slit
experiment by now yes we are must be
honest not everybody is yes yes these
are subatomic particles yes hey Marcus
even when they're not being observed
they act like waves okay good yes yes
when they're being observed yet as here
they change their form heart they turn
into particles okay there's a state of
awareness okay state of consciousness
and recorded yes states of consciousness
got it to the I another please right
that's very cynical you know what you're
finished in right now this is why
argument so he that makes you came at
the burden of proof so you're not going
to win to this what's right in SH all
right okay so so element when it observe
it behaves like particles now professor
Dean Radin this is in here who is the
right a commission goodness right Dean
Radin has demonstrated not only if you
look at particles that I behave it
differently
also if you think about them today
behave differently there's an
interaction with force as well as seeing
yes now cue you okay everybody okay you
heard what I said
I just am very super yet he says energy
energy I feel energy the rationality
that have consciousness in the devil
will please claim with the double slit
experiment
so three swap that when it's being of
good he has a certain weight my question
is did and I think answer look when it's
been well it can happen so much whether
the stubble suit when it's away too much
okay you can go ahead okay
when it is not being observed hug that
it acts as a way when it's being observe
how the acts as a particle by the same
thing it's used in the same ways wasn't
carried off to this no no Ali I'm coming
you off today go ahead and play again
okay okay are you often be going away to
game okay you got your president let's
just give you a punch line
unkind stop building out how to do drum
roll honey I don't know we have to do
the other those drum roll here get up
get out come on call a kind of a cannon
fire because you cannot please use your
car is G your pipeline when is like when
is what people does
yes have to wait yes yes when it's been
observed yaks impossible yes
can it act like a particle look we have
like a wave machine observe yes you can
activate everything that's in both way
evidence because evidence mean okay I
will give you a report on down alright
let's come right down one show letters
come I got a screenshot you guys went
the holistically they all come on wait a
second understand now when we observe it
yes just before it goes really yes yes
yes as a wave and a particle it's only
at the point of going through this
making it then decide what needs to go
pretty good mine color is actually
really irrelevant icescape but when I
listen back I wanna make a simple double
slaves everything why was positive yes
when it's not being observed
no cameras area they act like a wave
when it's real good a stock important
I'm saying when it get observed is there
any conclusion that you are we
my friend silence you are not Nylund to
me once night-night I know I'm not sure
honey
hey it's a whole thing no that's it just
a why I say why not why not
okay I think you think oh no no no you
think all these people
ally calm down I'm calm down breathe
believe it when you're talking about it
being observed can you be more
pacifically there you go the bet is no I
don't see I listen I just want to make
sure thinking oh you're looking about
hold on a second it's all you took the
right means physically look patterns all
physically feel have you lost which one
I mean which one have you wait for one
Danny have you lost weight sorry too
many last moment how you doing that is
really being looked at or girl we saw
something just which one
let me explain yes which one that's not
new Jesus and risen once again I'm going
to get my I said quickly
energy has person do you listen back up
I'm telling you if I go to a printer and
Press print print print print print
wouldn't use it semantics once again
Ally pirate Alitalia y le Cygne you got
my Jerry you're a mess why you did
America ought to tender why are you
holding - my name is any finish honey
why is a man taken obviously why you -
anything it is Ali may Allah okay we're
gonna go home and reevaluate your point
hahaha what is it if I go to my little
horrified by what about my friend when I
pressed a button something every system
isometric you do the same thing with the
particle when it be inspired and it's
been observed it's a special party I'm
asking let me observe let you go for
example because Ali's no forget it
tell me getting a green economy no and I
don't make I say hey you don't make
anybody not agree say anyway
I waited in my honey we're all gonna
make it very very simple you want me to
make it go you go on the field your
comprehension skills and up places good
enough for you carry guards and make it
clear to you
I Drive is led you're making any sense
all you today is are you saying very
simply when the particles are being
observed
all you two may have been look
hungry I mean I wanna make sure he knows
about the dress I wanna make you know I
want to know make sure he knows my
friend anything it's ple ple caring are
you too bright mean busy Ali I
immediately feel Carrie Jesse and all
means roses what you wanna do on top
which one now I'm gonna go and try to
preach on eating honey honey we turn
into every night night I've got a late
night night I mean I was running I
reached night-night oh you are so mean
by look you are coming right you are
going by if the particles of the night
and physically observed thank you are
you definitely line by you know when you
finish you can buy this minimally right
right agree to live in the third
anything right okay great
so let's go by if that is the case yes
this won't go through it again
right I respect that Dean wagon has
pointed out if it is observed it behaves
like a particle and when it's something
about over a second but also what this
new technology is taking place in 2016
when this answer is you also think about
it but it also behaves as a possible
just by thinking it or looking at it it
behaves
there's underneath valium of the
physicists that this is your doubtful
may webisode listen I write the name of
the song
now mr. Dean ruddy in this grapefruit in
CC Burma's destroyed it
he sent it from her house he called
candidate from around the world
he got candidate right down the hallway
to say when I say go or what you in
could visualize the environment
think about it they all did it just by
thinking it whether and it behaves like
particles there's a sale of awareness
where the particles new to behave as a
wave or a particle matter the fate of a
we're gonna see they all go around one
more time
Devon Yoga was what I see both your goal
I mean like you just on the boxer but
it'll punch behind you I prefer working
in other work today
approach you may move it now Mayweather
start I'm basic yet let me know but I'm
not going to come in Hollywood hotel let
me show you how I'm bringing ability you
stay in room once again when it's not
being observed know of the mission right
away call of the vision Russell when
they all judge me when our people
encryption of thinking about whatever
when it's not me I'll repeat the against
we've and understand and I'm going to
completely do anything yet
so you don't get your eating when it's
something on the [ __ ] away when it's
been a perfect image for your husband
my question is when feel of this where
is he thought about when they know in
the dead solid evidence they are going
to go away without having to go shoot
okay all right ohana sauce right high
tension for the engineer environment on
Troy can you see before this is that
would fit yes no that's another hole
donor retention and Yogananda
can you see there's a double-click the
electron particles or actions are now
deciding what needs to go in personal
and me how to behave despondent and how
did it behaviors work they are assault
wave impossible and employment to ensure
only through observation in a program to
screen charge and always also be right
at that point of the happiness oh okay
goes dragon fo Caligari when after his
boat why
because they're being of the commodity
boom much but one time is amazing
vocalist a family but your business any
other point on them look at what is my
goodness the village there's a priori I
didn't see one more time talking prior
then going through the double sleep and
and then I can evolve wave and particle
written we hope this is whole space of
the technology good boldface good your
associate now is only when they bring
deserve yeah they then decide a decision
is made or where as we continue behaving
as a possible ways of just make one
decision okay once it is old there is
consciousness theory okay buddy
it gave me so excited I'm John replied
and I replied just accompany me to look
like I like you sometimes it's the
battery out of life
jockeys revising arguments are made up
of the same stuff that everything else
is made of universe if we look at the
human body and go down to the skill we
find cells molecules to develop atomic
particles right pure anything the whole
universe is made up of energy not honor
even like no blind active level based on
the various reasons I disable everything
with a bracelet and we are all made of
the energy agent by serving on a
universal consciousness therefore energy
is constantly theory that is very hatred
this is mr. Haney basic the world
renowned possible Tori what's over
stereo girl can you bear it about
Santeria have you now answer it now what
he's doing is removing away I'm gonna
combat moving or I don't know clap in
Harrogate consciousness emission we go
buy fresh burnin oil i funny find it if
you found that you only trying to get up
come back to know we're all delivered to
know Carlo why not we talking let people
decide you know because I've even come
on
what if it wasn't working on now guys
look when it's been fired what my fear
from a guarantee is that at this moment
right here
Willis implies it's both particles and
highways
yes no problem party music - hey guys
world no forgiveness no space right in
folks payment no problem
party good and we my question is not
before me it's also I'm asking you when
it's going to be observed
absolutely having tried having a
positive it's acting like you see where
your problem is though if you were
program is giving you your country when
appropriate
ally I could see what your prom night in
is connected as you see what any problem
is hi Sally Sasser you probably know
have to take a common finish I'll use no
I have to pop you up there in the
homeland is mechanics a character nicely
honey Kerrigan is done it everyone I
mean I want anything any kind yes the
son Tom Craig give your now bro now why
program exist yet he see it makes a
crucial decision yet once you find out
is both possible to win push okay my
question is business when it's green
older recovers what their son well no
cameras conscious people good people
thinking I'll ask you when it goes with
that [ __ ]
why does the a classical particle
instead of acting microwave if it make a
decision this is our microwave I was
wait antibody
tough decision what systematic is the
example of u n-- of my printer if I go
to Washington with Princeton it doesn't
like to do our hit you the same way
these parts we observe okay is the
evidence or the combination on your
friends behind
I sent electronically Jerry's mark
please shows one where the positive are
being observed when they go through the
slit they act like a week thank you
can we all agree on one thing here human
you know how much less people if
something has ability to make a decision
I think I know I'm asking you I'm asking
you some basic restrictions if you've
got this is it hard ranges for us if we
look at about something Noah Cottrill an
old against the reaction environment I
guess uh be closed you guys okay no
reaction sorry laughter knows you have
to derive it is not if you look at the
tree it's very important what are the
trees been talk to me I'm here on no he
got the Christian no no no wait now what
did you say honey I'm not thank you Andy
and as often is agree yes if something
has the ability to make a decision yet
you have a state of consciousness right
this contest right right yeah what are
you questioning individually so what are
you questioning is over I said because
your question implies let me show you
something you're in questions like why
does it behave like a wave everything of
the corner yes
that's your question yes but you're
missing the point tell me the point the
point is the experiment is to prove
there is a space of consciousness it
doesn't matter how it's made
does that mean doesn't matter how very
good let's when you have a consciousness
original 50 prints what you mean have a
big question because the particles are
you throwing every time it's observing
are like a particle not a waste but
that's the finale I will eventually
honey let me finish Gary if I go to my
photographer and I play still using does
that mean hey Alec okay make it very
funny no it's system ser you CRE we are
usually listen we are using the double
T's primer no not to me honey honey what
is mountain washer over the hand II know
one counter it can I be this looks
reasonable time yet initially a double
snare Amanda son when the actual mean
customers are being observed the
extractor weights you want
okay I beg you shall not misuse I'm
begging you staring bulb at the same
time
okay let me show you Gary night-night
everything
can I get Helen can I see any jelly
serving on a suite of universe and
computerized on yourself therefore not
an energy is consciousness
there's my evidence cameras you're very
classy tell em I have it exactly the
mission the professor's the time is you
carry out this double experiment
none of them a communist Venus conscious
which will carry us carry us across to
speak on camera very very on the optical
yes he does let me of course she does
let's never will yes he does my shoes
yes he does on the subatomic level a
part of the religion on a stomach what
is a funny make - what he made okay
what's amazing too much assassins as
long time me question was always go
again
okay let's go against enemy very
handsome dude my dreams right watch this
watch know he headed to me you know he
said to me just now he said he says just
now Harry what he may provoke that is
Octopussy man so hopefully [ __ ]
mitosis it may so happen what they made
from cotton I mess in the water why is
it energetic construct okay the
unconsciousness quality on a subatomic
level okay yes it has been hope you will
carry right so the holiest and on agenda
I understand on that yeah I understand
you go we have an available Gary right
but I know about how you make for what
how you make for the big and anything I
know you want to find out everything I
know you want to bail out goodbye Eileen
Gary honey if I should do yes or no yes
I mean how'd you tell me where Muslims
everywhere from personalities or losing
seats my sperm comes from Ali once again
as you can look at I know you tell me
was an uncomfortable silence right now
is wrong it's another question we just
debunked
all right awesome I want you to listen
to this Holly listen telephone company
just hold on the iPod here right now
number let's go conquer party can you
hit it and literally how many scientists
was in trouble I want to know Ali
bulimia must be quantum run the
experiments again run the experiment
again yes well now if you can explain
this using common sense and logic if you
just explain this common sense yes do
let me know do let me know because
there's a Nobel Prize for you there's a
Nobel Prize for you right hold on a
second okay no crisis on a rookie that
is old and excitement because we gnarly
honey honey honey
now that was done I haven't here I don't
know now that was done here in dearly
hold her a second Tori what a Camry that
was done he has no Chris mix of Maine
and if you found 50 bung 2015 that was
wrong a little seven Terry's here hurry
what's it be right no no honey honey
nineteen Ali's not always honey come on
you gotta see